[Music]
so my name is Zack Kasper I'm a product
manager on the kubernetes team happy to
talk with you this morning
with me today is Roxanne de denna - and
Shu Xiang Chen works and is a product
manager on our stackdriver team and Xu
Chang is a technical lead on kubernetes
monitoring so hopefully we will go
through actually I'm going to go back
real quick
hopefully today we're going to talk to
you let's see about hybrid observability
we're going to cover a couple things
okay so one is I want to describe for
you how we think about hybrid how we
think about hybrid observability
specifically and then I want to spend
about five minutes or so talking about
kubernetes internal monitoring how we
use the system metrics to actually run
the system and then how does that impact
your application monitoring we'll walk
you through a couple of different
scenarios on GK on-prem specifically we
really want to focus on how this works
in the on-prem world and so we there's
multiple different patterns there and
then we're gonna hand it over to Rox
Honda and Shu Xiang and they're going to
walk us through a demo so how does that
sound sounds okay okay so I talked a
little bit about who we are I would love
to know a little bit about yourselves so
maybe I can see some hands how many
people are running kubernetes today okay
so this is most people in the room great
how many people are running gke okay
still posed to be a living room how many
people are using stackdriver
with their gke environment okay about
half that's pretty good and how about
Prometheus and Griffin ax users okay
that's probably about 2/3 of you okay
good to know I think we'll have
something interesting for everybody here
all right so let's kind of get started
here and this is how I think most
kubernetes deployments look like if
you're running in the cloud you have a
you're typically using the logging and
monitoring tools
come with that cloud platform so for us
that stackdriver
if you're running on premises you're
probably running elastic elastic search
with cabana Prometheus and Griffin ax
and so you know two very different tools
for two very different environments you
know what we want to envision is a world
where you have a hybrid solution that is
consistent across on premises as well as
in the cloud so the way we think about
hybrid is it's the same tooling it looks
the same it behaves the same it's in the
same screen particularly if I have
workloads running in both different
locations and so kubernetes actually
gives us the ability to do this right
the whole point of kubernetes was so
that we can abstract away the
infrastructure so we can have a
consistent environment no matter where
it's running right so we have this
amazing opportunity with kubernetes to
do this and so hopefully we'll present a
couple different patters to do that but
the way we think about it is we look at
stackdriver as the core piece that can
stitch together to give you on premises
view as well as a cloud-based view of
your workloads okay but before we kind
of get it too much into the specifics I
want to take a step back and talk a
little bit about how kubernetes
internally works so we have all these we
have all these components that rely on
system metrics such as the horizontal
pod autoscaler at the scheduler like we
need to understand your resource
utilization on your nodes for the
scheduler to work we need to know system
metrics for the cube kettle top so you
can see all the resource usage across
the customer the kubernetes doesn't give
us a sophisticated logging and
monitoring system out of the box but it
does have this system level components
so this is implemented with the metrics
API and the metric server and so the
these two components work the metric
server is actually going and scraping
the system level metrics from each
individual node
and then publishing that up so let's
take a look at the nodes themselves okay
so on the nodes obviously we have the
cube cube cuddle and then we have C
advisor how many people are familiar
with C advisor okay like a decent like
maybe a handful maybe 10 or so that's
good so C advisor is a resource usage
collector for containers it goes in it
auto discovers all your containers and
collects CPU memory use network storage
cetera so the C advisor and the Q cuddle
they work together these two components
gather all the metrics from the nodes
and publish those through the summer API
but going back to our bigger picture
this is what we call with those that see
advisor or the Q cuddle this is what we
call this core metrics pipeline this is
a core concept inside a kubernetes
itself but this is just for kubernetes
right this is nothing to do with your
application workloads this is all just
the internal workings so for my
applications I actually need a third
party monitoring solution so this is
where we get to now we need to talk
about okay well for GK I'm Prem what do
we use for that third-party monitoring
solution okay so let's let's take a look
at that what we want to do with GK I'm
Prem is get you the flexibility that you
want right we want you to use the right
tool for whatever your purposes are so
let's see a couple different scenarios
so maybe you have GK uh Prem it's
running your front end and the back end
is somewhere off the cluster and you
want to have end-to-end visibility for
that so maybe we want to use an existing
Splunk environment or maybe you want the
ease of a fully integrated cloud based
monitoring system stack driver may be a
great option for you maybe you're
running maybe you're interested in
running workloads in GCP as well as
on-premises right and then you need that
you need that view across both different
environments
so we want to get you the flexibility to
use whatever tool you're used to so
couple things so stackdriver are sorry
kubernetes out of the box
GK comprar of the box rather it comes
can pre configured with stackdriver
logging and monitoring we're also
shipping a prometheus anchor fauna
instance it's tailored for specifically
for GK on Prime and I'll talk you a
little bit about what we've done and
then we're working with our partners
Splunk and elastic to make sure that all
these systems work well together all
right so let's let's dive into stock
driver just a little bit and then I'll
cover the Prometheus and core phone at
the end so we're using three different
api's here three different stock driver
api's first ones monitoring so running
on the cluster we have a Prometheus
collector we have a pod what's called a
stock driver Prometheus kubernetes pod
and inside of that we have Prometheus
running that's that's configured
specifically for collecting these stock
driver metrics next to it is a pod
we call it the stock driver collector so
it's extracting the Prometheus metrics
and shipping them over to stock driver
monitoring API now we've done so couple
of things here on the Prometheus
instance to make sure it works well in
GK on-prem so we're doing things like
we've expanded the duration of the
buffer because we want to make sure that
like in a network outage that the
metrics are whole inside a stack driver
so we've expanded the buffer there a
couple other things like that
now this Prometheus instance this isn't
something you need to configure or worry
about this is really just an
implementation detail
okay so next we have the logging logging
is pretty straightforward so we have a
logging agent running on each of the
nodes those are aggregated up into a
locking collector it just so happens
that we're using fluent bit and fluent D
I flew a bit for the logging agent and
then fluent D for the collector again
this is just an implementation detail
the last piece is the metadata agent so
metadata is pretty important to us
because we want to give you a better
experience rather than just straight
logs and metrics so with metadata we
could stitch together into a much better
visibility across the cluster because we
actually have some some knowledge about
what is actually running under cluster
so with these three things so we have
logs metrics metadata these three things
would give you a much better experience
okay the last thing so I want to cover
Prometheus Agri fauna so not everybody
wants to use necessarily stock driver so
if we pretty much everybody to raise
their hand when I said like who's using
/ BTEC or prana so we're shipping
Prometheus tiger fauna with GK on Prem
we've done a couple things to make sure
it works well inside the environment the
first thing we wanted to do is we wanted
to give you a multi cluster view because
with GK I'm Prem you have your gonna
have multiple clusters out of the box
you have an admin cluster and a user
cluster so with what we've done is
configured Prometheus to have a multi
cluster view and you can you can you can
choose this kind of the scope that you
want to you look at so if you want to
see the multiple cluster view you can
use the graph on it instances running on
the admin cluster if you want to see
just the user cluster so say for example
you have an application specific cluster
and you want to give that out to an
application team they can use that graph
on a instance
then lastly for those that really enjoy
using Gravano you can actually build
dashboards that look at both the
Prometheus data for g/km prom as well as
data from your gke clusters stock driver
is a native data source for grow fauna
and so you can you can have dashboard
looking at both different clusters all
right so that kind of that kind of wraps
it up that's gives you just a general
overview of where we're at with g/km
from so a couple different options just
to review a cloud base out of the box
with stackdriver and then certainly
Prometheus core fauna as well as our
partners so with that I'm going to woken
up rocks onda and shusui thank you so
much that so next we're actually gonna
go through the project so we're gonna
actually look at how this works in
integrated with stackdriver
so for the purpose of this we actually
build a demo project this is the pet
clinic adorable pictures always work a
demos and the concept behind these is
that you have a series of owners so
let's see who we have in the owner list
and we're gonna try to figure out if
Shashank is on the list here and see if
we can add a pet for him so this is that
so you can have an idea of how these
services look like
and while Shashank does that let's talk
a little bit about what's happening on
the back end so we're gonna have two
clusters here one cluster is gonna run
on GK and on the cloud and one cluster
is going to be GK on pram and in this
scenario we're gonna have the API
gateway with three micro services in
each location and we're gonna push all
of the data to cloud spanner on GK so we
can actually monitor both the GK cluster
that's running on cloud and the GK
cluster
Braham within the exact same
visualization so once your shank has
completed this we're gonna go and see
how we can actually get access to this
information and throughout the demo
today I'm gonna show you three kind of
main pillars of the experience you had
get in stack driver the first one talks
is gonna talk about kubernetes
monitoring out of the box and this is a
beta product that we have launched the
second one what we're going to talk
about is gonna be around the custom
experience that you can actually build
so you can do your own custom dashboards
as well and then we're gonna talk about
the loading at the end
Shawshank is gonna take over and he's
gonna give us the idea of how you're
actually doing a troubleshooting so
right now we're gonna add some load
we're gonna generate some load to this
app in order to be able to to see some
alerts firing and how we do the
troubleshooting towards the end of the
demo so he's doing this right now in the
gk console for the gk clustered is
running on GC p you can see the two
clusters right there and then he's gonna
do the exact same process for the gk on
Prem cluster as well wonderful so let's
go to the stack driver UI as we're going
to the navigation within stackdriver we
can select kubernetes monitoring this is
the experience that I mentioned before
it is then out-of-the-box experience for
all users of kubernetes MGK right now as
as we're selecting this this is a beta
product for Star Driver everything that
you see on this page as long as you're
using gke as exactly as AK mention all
of these do not require a setup
everything gets collected and gets
reported for you so we have those two
clusters one is on cloud and one is on
pram and I want to give you a tour about
the capabilities that you're getting on
this page so at the top of the page we
have the alert timeline what we think
it's extremely core to the experience is
to know when things get alerted
the troubleshooting workflow is
fundamental and here we want to actually
showcase all of the alerts that you have
within your kubernetes environments that
span both cloud and on-premise cards
it's almost like a hidden app the more
alerts you have the darker the shade of
red and you get information about the
alerts that have fired underneath this
we have these three tabs infrastructure
workloads and services and we spend a
lot of time talking to customers and
getting to understand what are the
different flows personas and use cases
and we realized that in some cases
operators and developers might have
different interest or entry points so we
build these three different tabs to
satisfy somebody that's really
interested in focusing on nodes and
clusters and infrastructure approach but
we also want to cater to developers that
are more interested in deployments and
services as well so this gives a quick
entry point to all of those experiences
we're starting with the infrastructure
tab and the two clusters are as you can
see here we are going to open the GK
cluster running on cloud and as you can
the table itself has an almost like a
hierarchy built into it and while we
know that kubernetes in GK does not have
a hierarchy of per se but the meta data
allows us to read all of these labels
and actually build an intuitive way of
reporting this information so you can
see your cluster the nodes in it
the pods within that node all the way to
the container and this level of drill
down can be really helpful as you're
trying to do troubleshooting or they're
trying to find particular things so you
you have the groupings to help you to
navigate this really easily at the same
time the table itself gives you at a
glance information around the resource
the number of parts that are ready the
number of incidents the CP utilization
and memory on the workloads page we have
a hierarchy that spans clusters
namespaces deployments pods and
containers so you see that there is this
in there are different ways where things
get clusters and the hierarchy is really
important as a way of getting to the
drill down that's more significant to
the workflow that you're interested in
and we have for the let's pick for the
API gateway for deployment let's click
on one of those and actually look at
some of the details of a pod so for
every single entry within this table you
get a details panel that gives you
information gives out-of-the-box metrics
that are already created you get these
charts pre-populated for you so it
requires no setup we have an integration
with logging as well so you're gonna get
a high level histogram of the logs for
this particular pod and you're gonna get
a selection of logs filtered by severity
for this part as well and of course
that's never enough so you're gonna be
able to very quickly click on the entire
logging experience you're gonna remain
the context that's gonna stay the same
so here we are in the full logging
experience in the GCP console but we are
only looking at that particular cluster
at that particular part that we are
evaluating and that particular time span
so you can go and end up doing your
troubleshooting there and do more
filtering and then we have details
information as well so every single as
we're going through all of this
information the details are really
important and you're able to go and get
logs and metrics for every single entry
within those tables and of course we
have a deep integration with the
kubernetes and Jiki teams so you can go
in and actually get a lot more detailed
information from the gke page in context
so when we go back to stock driver we
can actually see the third column is
services this gives you an ability to
actually go through the entire hierarchy
with services as well and gives you
information within kind of the same span
of cluster name space pod and a service
pod and containers so let's go back to
infrastructure for a second and the
table itself
has been inverted hierarchy and it's
interesting to navigate but one of the
things that is sometimes problematic
when you have hundreds of these entities
is really hard to understand patterns
and being able to come up with insights
of the way that maybe there is a trend
out there that you're not able to see in
a table format so we build this bubble
visualization just mostly because we'd
really like bubble visualizations now
but the idea is that it it's gonna
empower you to use metrics so we have a
CPU usage on the x axis and on the y
axis memory usage each bubble represents
a note the size of the bubble represents
the number of pods in that node so how
big the the node is and then the color
represents the health so if you have if
it's a light gray it means that is
healthy and red means that it's an
incident and as you can see there are
all of these different clusters that are
forming there are all of these patterns
of information this is an exploratory
tool that we're launching in beta as
well and we are trying to make this as a
way of using the the data that you have
the information that you have and come
up with interesting insights about
trends that are happening across these
it's important to mention that right now
we're looking at nodes that span both
cloud and on-premise a fascinating way
of understanding this behavior where at
the end of the day what we want to get
to a position in especially with Anthes
is that you shouldn't care if something
is on prime or on GCP and you need to
have a single tool that manages all of
these things for you so you can your
monitoring solution is in one space so
so far we talked about the
out-of-the-box experience for kubernetes
and you came within stackdriver
and while we understand that every
single out-of-the-box experience out
there and is amazing up to 80% of the
time and then you're gonna have some use
cases where you're gonna need to build
something custom so stock driver allows
you to get access to all of this
information
and build your own custom experience as
well so what we developed is this tool
called metric Explorer that gives you
the ability to actually query all of the
metrics that are coming in all of your
system level metrics and these metrics
come in either from GCP or from one pram
you find them within the exact same
space you can apply as you can see here
there is a lot of information we have a
lot of lines on that chart and might not
be read about so maybe we want to apply
filtering so you can benefit from using
advanced filtering at the same time we
can group things by we can add a lot of
functionality and in aggregate this
information as well and one of the
things that we build is that sometimes
we we we try to do it with filtering we
do a good job of bringing in a lot of
data but it's too much data to make it
meaningful so if you introduced modes
and options for you to do an outlier
mode so you can pick to always show the
top five outliers within your space or
top 10 or top 15 the number that you can
and make these charts really meaningful
for you when you go into know where the
problems are so you can investigate a
lot faster and as you can see here
there's a lot of trial and error so we
can spend quite a few minutes until we
figure out what are the right metrics
what are the right filters until you
build your great chart and you don't
want to do that every single time you
log into Star Driver so we have the
ability for you to be able to save these
charts and save them in a new dashboard
add them to an existing dashboard and
these charts can be easily shared
through your URL with all of your
colleagues so you have the same share
the same context so let's look at a
custom dashboard next so we can actually
see this capability live and this is a
hybrid dashboard so every single chart
that you see on this graph displays data
that is collected from both cloud and
a lot of this information is being
brought to you in in in one single - but
you don't have to create multiple
dashboards you don't have to go to
multiple consoles have different
experiences everything can come in one
place you can easily add more charts and
make this customizable and then you can
easily play and delete things so you can
make this space really meaningful to
your team and we talked about the custom
experience and next I want us to focus a
little bit around alerting we know at
the end of the day monitoring
proactively its time consuming it's
something that you won't be able to just
spend all of your day looking in front
of a screen and waiting for something to
go wrong so we need to be really smart
about our alerts so we created an
integrated alerting experience so let's
try to start the process of creating an
alert as you can see the interface that
you have access to right now is the same
interface that we showed earlier is the
metric Explorer interface you have you
have the ability once you kind of get to
know the system and start playing with
metric Explorer that is the one-stop
shop for creating your dashboards
creating your alerts you're using the
same workflow we want to make sure that
you don't have to have a ramp up of
learning curve for each and every
experience so you have the exact same
filled metric capability filters all of
these things are brought in within the
same workflow so of course you can edit
these you can add notifications you can
add critical documentation these are
really important we really encourage all
of our customers to use documentation
heavily in their alerts and linked to
dashboards and provide links to to books
as well so let's look at some of the
incidents that we just created so these
are will be displayed so you can
actually have a list of all of your
incidents and these can span alerting
policies and these can span both the
environments that you have on cloud and
on a pram and now that we've covered
kind of just to bring everything
together
we talked at the beginning about the
out-of-the-box experience we're hoping
that that experience can give it gives
you an option to have visibility without
any setup and be able to sustain
probably the large majority of the use
cases then we talked about the custom
option if you want to build your custom
dashboards that are hybrid that span
both clouds you have that option as well
and how to build really really smart
alerting
that can help you navigate how not to
get woken up at 3 o'clock in the morning
but because he created this alerts and
we added some load to the app at the
beginning of the demo
I think shashank just got paged and he's
gonna show us what happens once you get
an alert and how we troubleshoot this so
Shoshana okay
ah thanks Roxanne de so this is awesome
I'm going to give you a demo about what
a typical classical troubles within
scenario in our daily work so as Swee so
we usually like in kind of where a
common scenario is that when you
application becomes receiving it becomes
way more used by customer you're
receiving more and more traffic and in
the meantime some of your server become
slow or response and responsive and
usually it's like the moment there's
some uncle engineer were jumping and
they figure out what's happening and we
want to understand is it due to a bad
machine due to a bad deployment or due
to something misconfigure and it's
become more and more complicated if
especially when you have distributed set
up like a hybrid also like a hybrid set
have you have GK on cloud you have
kubernetes like on praying or GK on bran
and you're also distributed across many
different areas that is the scenario
will try to demo here ok so as as you
may recall from like maybe 10 minutes
ago when Roxanne dastar had her demo we
generally some Chaffey to both of my GK
cluster and GK on Brancaster so while
she's demoing I as an uncle engineer of
Lisp a clinic
besides I've been paged so this is the
alert I've received so rock doctor will
send me an alert talking about something
HTTP server request [ __ ] for 500 is too
high and based on the documentation and
no this is like it means too many 500
has been returned for my services this
is a little bit concerning to me because
our returning 500 means my customer may
be experiencing this outage now so let's
take a look at what incident detail page
stackdriver tells me so as you can see
here we are receiving a run like 12
requests per second of 500 for the
application for the service api gateway
this is a little bit concerning to me
because api gateway is the interface of
my application so as sweet
I go to my predefined custom dashboard
which has almost all of the information
of the important metrics I curious about
my hybrid setup so as you can see on the
top two charts so the top the first
chart on the top left corner this is the
hybrid of the request can't go to both
cluster in my hybrid setup as you can
see I receive around 150 requests go to
magic a on print cluster and a run 200
request go to magic a cluster this is
working as intended because this is how
my load balancer configures all right so
let's take a look at the top right chart
so this is the error rate so from this
chart is give me very strong signal that
something is wrong in my GK on print
cluster because you can see here off the
500 are coming from my GK on print
Custer so as a developer my first
interaction is I try to dive into this
cluster GK on printer through the back
what the issue will be but as like the
Google as I best practice tell me that
the first thing I need to do at this
moment is to medicate the issue so one
of the various
classical ways we just drain this g/km
Brancaster and fight over the trophy to
gk class sir before we do that I have
one more thing I want to confirm for
additional safety so let's go to
kubernetes monitoring view the thing I
want to confirm is if I fail what that
means magic a caster will receive the
double size of the traffic I want to
make sure magic a caster can sustain the
load so that's where that's why I come
to this infrastructure view as I can see
here so CPU and memory usage for both
clusters are run like a 20% if I expand
the GK class I I see there have six
nodes and each of nose is running around
20% CPU utilization
I run 20 to 30% of memory utilization so
it is like if you have a plenty of space
so I can failover I think that's a safe
move at this moment ok so let's go
through this g/km friend Craster i just
drain the traffic into this cursor and I
go to this kubernetes cloud SSH and then
I just double the size this is to
simulate a fire over
so in Rio we will have like a more other
once load balancer config would do but
in this demo we just simulating this way
ok so as we go back into this dashboard
I mean usually the load balancer would
like take around one or two minutes for
the traffic to migrate so eventually we
will see the on prank caster traffic
goes down and then GK castle traffic
goes up but we will not wait the time
here to wait for that we will go back
after I finished my demo and then to
verify this is the behavior ok so that I
believe the current outage is reasonable
recently medicated as a developer I want
to debug the root cause of the issue so
that's the moment I go to my service tab
because that's the place that's the
thing that's alerting I see this
incident caller has give me very good
hints like something is
in on-prem caster this is another way we
can narrow down the issue and we go to
like this incident call and keep telling
me where I shall focus my attention to
so this is the API gateway I should take
a look at this part so that's open this
taught interview I see there's open
incident that's too many 500 has been
written from this container let's look
at the metrics for this specific part as
you can see containers restart there's
not nothing restart which seems great
memory utilization is flat because this
app is not memory heavy a most of data
is stalling in the class banner for CPU
utilization we see like from 115 or 10
minutes ago they have some CPU spike
that's expected because we generate a
lot of traffic story usage is also flat
because we don't write anything network
usage is higher this is also like caused
by the traffic increase okay so if just
looking at a mattress seems everything
is looking great
it means my kubernetes appear our
infrastructure is running healthy then
what could be the issue here at this
moment this is the moment where lock can
help us a lot so if you go to lock tab
we see the lock race here
this gives me a very obvious signal
something is wrong because my
application is writing a lot of air
locks as you can see this is a run like
40 percent or one third of blogs are
written as arrowrock this is very
suspicious because normally we don't
write so many aro dogs and we go to the
snippy we see okay
that's indeed some error logs here let's
go to blocks we were to see the more
details so this is already I expanded
arrow so we can see for the detail here
we can see this is a Java Runtime
special exception have been thrown and
it give me the full stack trace so I can
go to
the where the thing that happening in a
very concrete detail so let's see what
this means
let's just fetch okay factually saying
let's go through the code so this is
where my our code base is so just do a
grab off above error message I can see
this is something that is written in the
API gateway controller in Java and then
line 54
let's just open the file unable to fetch
okay so at this moment it's very quite
clear to me like this error message or
this 500 error has been thrown because
somebody write this line of very
suspicious functionality it's basically
just like it was a coin before returning
a successful request so there's a 550
percent chance that you will not be able
to get your trophy sorry get a correct
results so till this moment so we have
already identified a blue cost the root
cause is somebody Armada introduced a
back into the code and then deploy into
my GK on precaster so other thing for me
the next step for me every career I was
just like fixed the back in a code
redeploy into the GTA Umbreon cluster
and then strain the g/km Brancaster then
we can make our application back to
normal so this is the end of the demo
[Music]